Hey there, in this video, I'm going to show you how to use ParamWiner to find a fat get
cache poisoning vulnerability, as documented in my recent web cache entanglement research.
So for our target, I'm using an application I built myself. So it's very simple. But the
reason it's vulnerable is because I'm using the rack cache module. At the time I'm recording this,
this is currently a zero date. So anyone using rack cache is vulnerable. So I've just loaded this
homepage, it's triggered a few requests, which we can see and I'm going to select everything in scope,
right click, go to bulk scan and choose fat get which is going to tell ParamWiner to scan for fat
get poisoning. We get loads of options just stick with the default ones. If you can't see the confirm
button because your screen is too small like mine, then just press Ctrl Enter. So if you check over on
the extender tab, you'll see we've got some information telling us this attack has been launched
and completed. And if you're using the community version of Burp rather than Pro, then any findings
will appear over here as well. But because we're using Pro, we should instead find this find the
findings appear on our dashboard, such as over here. So if we take a look at this, we'll see it's found
that it's taken this callback parameter from the query string and it's put it in the body of the
request and it's stuck a canary on the end of the base value. And this has been reflected back in the
response. So we'll see we get a hit for it. And then it's recent the request as is but without our
canary in the request. And the response still contains our canary showing that we've poisoned the cache
on this page. You can see it's done so using a cache buster. So it probably hasn't affected any real
users, but we've demonstrated that the vulnerability is there. So now let's just have a go at seeing if
we can replicate this issue and exploit a real web browser. So we're going to take the request
request and send it to the repeater. And if you look in the proxy, you'll see the URL that our victim's
going to load is the one referenced on the homepage over here. So that's what we want to poison
this URL. So I'm going to grab that.
That's our target. And we're going to change the callback to just to alert. And hopefully
that will do the job. Okay, you can see our alert thing hasn't come back, it just says load. And
that's because we've got a cache hit. As you can kind of tell from the headers here. So I'm going to send a
purge request, which is going to helpfully delete this cache entry. And now you can see we do have
alert coming back. If we change it to get, we've still got alert coming back and we have a cache hit.
And if we take this and get rid of the body, so now we're sending what a browser would send,
we still get alert coming back. And so finally, if I take that URL, copy it,
paste it into the browser. No, I'm sorry, if I load the homepage in the browser,
the browser will fetch that URL, get poisoned and alert will pop up, hopefully.
Oh, dear. So why hasn't this worked? Well, it's probably because
no, I'm not sure. Why hasn't this worked? Let's have a look at what the browser sent. Okay, it's because
the browser has cached this JavaScript file itself in its client side cache. So if I had a force reload
the exploit files, fantastic.